-♪♪ "Tonight Show Dance Battle" ♪♪
♪♪ Yeah ♪♪
-Whoo! I got this.
-Here we go.
-I got this.
-Yep.
Now, this here is
the dance-move generator.
We're gonna take turns hitting
this button right here,
which will randomly select
a never-before-seen dance move.
-Okay.
-Whoever's turn it is has to
make up a dance for that move.
-Okay.
-And the best dancer wins.
-[ Laughs ]
-But this isn't...
[ Cheers and applause ]
This isn't just any old dance
battle we're doing tonight.
I want to spice things up
and make it
a three-way dance battle.
-What? What?
-Let's bring out
our third competitor.
He was recently
nominated for a Tony
for his performance
in "Lobby Hero."
You can see him on
the FX show "Atlanta"
and alongside Sterling in
his new movie, "Hotel Artemis."
Please welcome
Brian Tyree Henry!
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Hey! Yeah!
Ahhh!
-[ Laughs ]
-Ahh!
-Yes!
-Come on! That's what's up.
Welcome. Always good to see you.
Always good to see you, buddy.
-Hey!
-All right.
-Oh, man.
-Well, get ready.
Now we're competitors.
-Whoo!
-Now we're competitors.
-Okay.
Here we go.
Brian, Sterling,
I hope you're ready to dance.
-Whoo!
-Sterling,
why don't you go first.
You're our guest tonight.
Let's start the generator first.
And then, when you're ready,
you press the button on there.
I see some good ones. Come on.
-Big bucks, big bucks.
-I see something with
the word "pickle" in there.
[ Laughter ]
-You got this one, bro.
-This is gonna be a dance craze
that's gonna sweep the nation.
-I got you. I got you.
-You got
"I Lost Control of My Butt."
Roots...
[ Up-tempo rock music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh, my gosh!
-Oh!
-Oh! All right.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Whoa! Whoa! All right! Whoa!
All right! Hey! All right!
All right, you lost control.
You lost control.
-You got it?
-You lost control.
That's all right.
-It's okay?
-Everything's okay.
No one got hurt.
-Oh!
-Not one got hurt.
You just lost control
of your butt.
That's all. No one got --
-Bro, I get it, man.
We've all been there.
We've all been there, Jimmy.
-Well, thank God
you gave him your phone.
You would have called like
a thousand people right now.
All right, I don't know if --
I can't top that.
Okay.
-Come on, bro. Come on.
-That was unbelievable.
It's my turn.
Let's start the generator.
Here we go.
I saw "Tickle Me" something.
What is that?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"I Just Watched 'This Is Us.'
Now I'm at the Club."
All right, Roots, let's do it.
[ Up-tempo hip-hop music plays ]
-Yeah.
Uh-oh. Oh!
[ Both laugh ]
-No! No!
-He can't take it.
He can't take it.
We know. We know. We know.
We all know.
-I've been there.
-We all know.
We did it.
-All right, we all know.
All right, all right.
-I get that.
-All right, now, here we go.
Brian, you are up.
Let's start
the dance-move generator.
-Okay.
-You got it. You got it.
-"Dad Gets Turnt."
-He's got the hat.
He's got the hat.
-I got the hat on.
-He's got the hat.
[ Mid-tempo rap music plays ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Hey!
Oh, wait! Whoa! Wait! Dad!
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
That was it. That was it.
That was it.
That was...
-It's always that right there.
-"Dad Gets Turnt."
That was -- That's a...
All right, all right, all right.
All right.
All right, you guys
are clearly the better dancers.
Why even compete
against each other,
when we could do
one final dance together?
-Hey.
-Let's do it.
Let's bring it together.
-Dance-move generator.
-All right.
-Ready? All three of us?
-All right. Come on.
-1, 2, 3...
"B.T.H. Shuffle."
-What is that?
-I don't even know
what that means.
-It stands for "The
Brian Tyree Henry Shuffle," man.
I made up a dance
a long time ago.
I do it at parties.
It goes to any song.
I just got to show y'all.
Show y'all. Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you know it?
-Y'all got me, right? Come on.
Come on, Brown. You know this.
It's very simple.
Come on. Wait.
1, 2, 3...
And 1, 2...
Take it back.
Skip a bunch.
Turn in, turn in, turn in.
Turn out.
All right.
Here we go, here we go.
To the left.
To the right.
Pull it back.
Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey!
Come on.
Once and a bump.
Take it back.
Skip, skip, skip.
Hey!
Take it back.
Come on.
Turn in, turn in, turn in.
Turn out, turn out.
To the left.
To the right.
Hey! Hey!
Hey!
Come on.
-[ Laughs ]
-Come on, Jimmy!
Hey!
Skip, skip. Hey!
-[ Cries ]
-Come on! Come on, Jimmy!
Come on!
-I can't do it right now.
That's all I can do.
That's all we have.
"Tonight Show Dance Battle."
Our thanks to Sterling K. Brown,
Brian Tyree Henry.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with
Willie Geist, everybody.
-Skip, skip, skip.
Skip, skip.
Now come on. Come on.
Turn in, turn in, turn in.
Now out. To the left.